the article you wrote was really talking
about
how you know i think
p from your words people in the united
states
a lot of them particularly younger
people don't recognize
how different our society is from other
societies out there
and in particular i remember one part of
infidel where you're talking about
um being in this in this dutch setting
where there was things being debated
with regard to islam
you know is is islam violent is it not
violent and you stood up
and and you gave your opinion and it you
know
the your sense of being in a society
where
it was okay to to to voice
you know your your feelings and you
didn't have to
worry about being told to to be quiet in
dutch society
um except i was in the end
you know that's all right right to self
censor and
and so on but but again to go back you
know
when america um liberated itself
from british rule about 244 245 years
ago
things were really different there was i
mean and i remember
reading about how religious uh freedom
and the freedom of conscience and the
freedom of speech were
regarded as very important and it's one
of the
you know that fast amendment is
something that americans then really got
into
trying to establish and achieve
and the generations that worked hard to
do that
uh obviously value it way more than the
generations that inherited
those values and inherited the
prosperity and inherited all these
various kinds of freedoms
and so the challenge now is for those
who inherited it who don't know what it
is to struggle for
things because they've never had to
struggle for things
uh it's for those generations now to
continue to pass it on to the next
and the next and the next generation and
in europe
uh before 1989 and i wasn't in europe
before 1989
but if you looked at the conversations
they were having and the things that
they were writing about
these freedoms meant something to them
because of the cold war
after 1989 i mean in a decade or so
we started to sink into moral relativism
we started to sink
into you know a mental and intellectual
discourse where we were saying well you
know that freedom of speech
uh actually it's kind of rude uh why
let's just let let's just let it go uh
you know talking about islam and
criticizing islam salman rushdie being
threatened
others other muslims and ex-muslims
being threatened
uh that was presented as of course they
have the right to say these things of
course
salman has a right to write his book
but he shouldn't provoke why provoke
and unfortunately that sentiment has now
made its way to america
so it's yeah it's interesting for me to
see
how easy it is for those who've
inherited freedoms and prosperity to let
go of those things
right and it's interesting in your book
you know you talk about moving from
place to place
and the increasing use of the hijab and
other
you see other manifestations of islam
kind of spreading as you move from place
to place
and i remember a portion of the book
where you're talking about
you know they sent a reporter uh back to
kind of dig up dirt for a story about
you
and i think it was kenya where uh you
saw a video of kenya
and your brother was back there and you
noticed people walking on the street
with
a lot more you know wearing um you know
the hijab
and so you've seen this spread of this
ideology which restricts
freedom of speech and and freedom of
religion and actually
is very much like the cancel culture
that's growing up here in the united
states
when you now look back on your time
moving from
uh kenya to um the netherlands and then
moving to the united states
how has europe changed over that time
and then how do you think the united
states has changed really since
i think the first time you were here was
2008 is that right
2006. so the first time i came here was
2002 but that was very brief and then
i kept coming back but i actually moved
here permanently in 2006 september of
2006.
so i mean i i saw this greg what
what was in the early days gradual
but later on it seemed to go with uh
a frightening pace uh a frightening
speed
but i left somalia in the 1970s and i
don't remember women
covered from head to toe i don't
remember any i knew that everybody was a
muslim or
i thought of everyone as a muslim but i
don't remember any kind of
specific religious fundamentalism
and i could see that contrast because
when we left somalia and went
to saudi arabia my god that was a
different country yes the women were
walking in
black garb from head to toe wearing
gloves
and socks and separated from the men
and all this over you know
98 degrees 100 degrees
fahrenheit so that was quite something
there were every few feet there was a
mask
there was a lot of religious expression
and not just expression but a lot of
religious imposition
and and oppression the the atmosphere
felt
oppressive and it's one of the things
that i'm really
most grateful for that my family were
departed from saudi arabia
before i went into puberty and then we
went to ethiopia and then again i saw
that the
people might be religious but it was
very much more relaxed if you take that
standard
of saudi arabia and kenya even more
relaxed
because most kenyans around me at that
time were christians not muslim
there were some muslims and i remember
my mother going to school and demanding
that
i wear the head scarf and a pair of
trousers under my school uniform
and the teacher in my primary school
what you guys call elementary school
refused to do so and said you know here
are the rules we have a school uniform
you abide by that
and my mother just went away feeling sad
and disappointed
but no luckily didn't pull me out
fast forward when this documentary is
made in 2006
and the camera crew from the netherlands
go off to kenya to investigate my family
life
i was just shocked yes you're absolutely
right stunned to see how the streets of
kenya had changed
they visited both of the schools that i
went to the elementary school and the
high school
and now instead of the old girl wearing
a head scarf or none
i would say most of them were wearing
head scarf so i remember just looking at
that visual and thinking
that has just only happened in 10 years
that's just in one decade
and then same thing in europe the muslim
communities the muslim minorities in
europe
were very much at least
to me it looked like in the early days
they were attempting to assimilate
and yes i did see women walking about
foot behind their husband three feet
behind their husbands and pushing
baby prams but in a decade again
that community has changed dramatically
now you go to those neighborhoods and
it's not just
the married women with the children who
are covered from head to toe there are
more and more women
and it becomes stifling because you
can't really get out of it you know you
probably don't want to wear
the hijab or or the burqa but others
will come to you and enforce it
and and then the women who don't want
and the families who don't want they get
out of these neighborhoods
and so in europe what you see is this
establishment
of muslim majority ghettos where sharia
law
is informally enforced and that again is
a product of dawa which is the
presentation i gave to you and your
colleagues
in 2017
you